WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY A
JUDGE ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLICCONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING ARE
COMMITTING COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. TODAY BOTH OF THE
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK UP POP UP ONE WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO AND MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE
DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WELCOME THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TOP
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HIS THAT
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE- HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. FIRST WE WILL
CONSIDER THE ISSUES ON THE VOTE
ON THE CALENDAR. THE FOLLOWING
ISSUES WILL BE HELD OPEN TODAY
ISSUES NUMBER. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT AND TEN WHAT
THIS MEANS IS THAT THERE WILL
BE NO VOTE ON THESE ITEMS TODAY.
WE'LL TAKE THEM UP AT A
DIFFERENT TIME. NEXT THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES WILL BE VOTED
ON AT THE END OF THE HEARING
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT ISSUES.
FIVE SIX NINE ELEVEN. THROUGH
NINETEEN. NOW WE WILL GO INTO
THE DISCUSSION ITEMS. THE FIRST
ISSUE THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED IS
THE STATE COMPTROLLER
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PAYROLL PROJECT. THE
DEPARTMENT MAY IS MAY BE READY
TO PRESENT AND WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY.
JENNIFER YOU MIGHT NEED TO UN
MUTE YOUR MIKE. SHARE AND
SENATOR NIELSEN MY NAME IS
JENNIFER URBAN AND I AM THE
CHIEF BUDGETS AND ACCOUNTING
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS ASEAN'S
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUT TO
CHANGE PROPOSALS. THE PERSON
BEFORE YOU WAS ISSUE TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECT. AS IT WAS REQUEST SIX
POSITION. AND ONE WOMAN TERM.
AN ASSOCIATED TO SOME THE CAL
STATE HEROES. THROUGH THE
CONTINUING OF THE COW
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE THE
RESOURCES WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE PROJECT ACTIVITIES THAT
WILL DRIVE THE PROCESS OF
ASSESSING OPTIONS AND DESIGNING
A NEW ST MARTIN PERSONNEL AND
PAYROLL SOLUTION. THREE
CHALLENGE TO BE PROCUREMENT
WHICH INCLUDE A PER CALLED
PHASE. WE'RE HAPPY ANSWER ANY
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ANY COMMENTS FOR FINANCE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF
THIS PROJECT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY COMMENTS FROM THE OHIO.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN METZGER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WITHHOLD ACTION ON THESE BUDGET
PROPOSALS UNTIL THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
APPROVES CRITICAL PLANNING
DOCUMENTATION FOR THIS PROPOSED
PROJECT. THE DOCUMENTATION WILL
ALLOW OUR OFFICE TO MORE FULLY
ASSESS AND RECOMMEND ACTION ON
THESE PROPOSALS IN THE MEANTIME
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE THOROUGHLY EVALUATE
THIS COMPLEX AND COSTLY PROJECT.
THE PRELIMINARY BASELINE COST
FOR THIS PROJECT IS
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
PRELIMINARY BASELINE SCHEDULE
IS AT LEAST FIVE YEARS. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BEGIN TO
EVALUATE THE PROJECT BY ASKING
KEY QUESTIONS INCLUDING WHAT IS
THE RECOMMENDED SOLUTION FOR
THIS PROPOSED PROJECT AND WHAT
OTHER SOLUTIONS WERE CONSIDERED.
IN LIGHT OF THE STATE'S
PROJECTED OUT YEAR DEFICITS IS
NOW AN APPROPRIATE TIME TO
EMBARK ON SUCH A COSTLY
PROJECTS. AND HOW WILL BE
ADMINISTRATION MITIGATE RISKS
AND ADDRESS ISSUES TO AVOID THE
OUTCOME OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY PROJECT WHICH IS THE
PREDECESSOR TO THE PROPOSED C.
S. P. S. I. T. PROJECT. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO DIRECT
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE A
REPORT WITH ALL OF THE OPTIONS
AND TECHNICAL SOLUTIONS
CONSIDERED. AND THEIR
ASSOCIATED PRELIMINARY COST
SCHEDULE AND SCOPE. FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISH AN OVERSIGHT
FRAMEWORK FOR THIS PROPOSED
PROJECT. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
FOR EXAMPLE CONSIDER BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES
MONTHLY OVERSIGHT MEETINGS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OUR
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO RECEIVE PROJECT
UPDATES AND REVIEW OVERSIGHT
DOCUMENTS. AS WELL AS
POTENTIALLY QUARTERLY
LEGISLATIVE BRIEFINGS TO UPDATE
OTHER LEGISLATIVE STAFF ON THE
PROPOSED PROJECT THIS FRAMEWORK
COULD BE REVISITED ONCE THE
PROPOSED PROJECT BEGINS
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF I COULD ASK THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE I
ACTUALLY- APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE L. A.
AND I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN
ADDRESS THOSE QUESTIONS I WAS
MY QUESTION WAS GOING TO BE HOW
DOES THIS INTERFACE WITH FISCAL
BUT I THINK IT- THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THE L. A. R. R. R. R.
PRETTY IMPORTANT GIVEN THIS.
THE CHALLENGES WE'VE FACED WITH
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS IN THE
PAST- COULD YOU PLEASE ADDRESS
THE ISSUES THAT THAT THE- L. A-
RAISED. YES I CAN MANAGER MY
NAME IS CHRIS MAYO AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM PROJECT I
COULD WALK THROUGH THEM TOP TO
BOTTOM AND I ALSO- CONNECT YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT- HOW WILL
INTERFACE WITH CISCO. SO WHY IS
THIS YEAR PREPARE FOR PROPOSING
YOUR REPLACE U. NINE CARE YOU.
UNIFORMS APRIL SYSTEM. WELL
QUITE SIMPLY TODAY'S SYSTEM
FORTY FIVE OLD. IT WAS FIRST
DEVELOPED BEFORE THE ADVENT OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IN THE
STATE. AND OVER THE PAST FOUR
AND A HALF DECADES NEW
PROCESSES HAVE BEEN DEFINED AND
PERSONNEL AND PAYROLL SYSTEM
HAS BEEN EXPANDED TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS. THE EMPLOYEE POPULATION
HAS GROWN AND THE COMPLEX
PAYROLL RULES KEEP COMING.
TODAY THERE ARE OVER THIRTY
NUMBER THIRTEEN UNDERLYING
SYSTEMS THAT COMPRISE THE
OVERALL PAYROLL SYSTEM AND
THEY'RE NOT VERY WELL
INTEGRATED. THEY'RE NOT EASY TO
OPERATE MAINTAIN AND THEY'RE
VERY TIME CONSUMING TO CHANGE.
SOME OF THE PRIMARY REASONS WE
NEED TO REPLACE THE PAYROLL
SYSTEM INCLUDE THE NEED TO
HAVE. THE ABILITY FOR TIMELY
IMPLEMENTATION OF CHANGES IN
LAWS AND RULES RELATED TO
PAYROLL AND PROCESSING OF-
PERSONNEL ACTIONS. WE NEED AN
EMPLOYEE SELF SERVICE AND
MANAGER SELF SERVICE CAPABILITY
THAT'S NOT CAPABLE- ACROSS OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS. WE NEED
AUTOMATED DATA VALIDATION AND
COMPLIANCE VERIFICATION CHECKS.
IMPROVED ACCESS TO DATA
REPORTING AND DATA ANALYTICS-
CLEARLY WE NEED BETTER
INTEGRATED BUSINESS PROCESSES
ACROSS THE LINES OF BUSINESS
THE PAYROLL SYSTEM ENCOMPASSES
AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS
INCLUDING OF COURSE A TECHNICAL
ARCHITECTURE REFRESH AGAIN THE
SYSTEM IS FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD
AS OF AS OF RIGHT NOW. WELL ALL
THESE REASONS ARE GENERALLY
EXISTED- SINCE THE NEED TO
REPLACE THE PAYROLL SYSTEM WAS
FIRST IDENTIFIED OVER TWENTY
YEARS AGO- PRIOR CLAIMS ABOUT
THE SYSTEM BEING ABLE TO CRASH-
EXISTENCE- THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT I SPEAK UP TODAY. THE
SYSTEM IS NOT ABOUT TO CRASH
AND IT'S THROUGH THE YOU KNOW
THE GREAT EFFORTS OF THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IT STAFF.
AND THE STAFF OF THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TO CONTINUE TO
MAINFRAME MAINTAIN THE
APPLICATIONS UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE. NONE THE LESS THE
SURVEY OF ALL THESE FOLKS
INDICATE THAT 85% OF THEM AGREE
THAT A NEW SYSTEM WOULD RESOLVE
MANY OF THE LEGACY PAYROLL
SYSTEM LIMITATIONS. SO THE SCO
IS DETERMINED TO PROVIDE A
BETTER MODERN PAYROLL SYSTEM
THAT PROVIDES YOU IMPROVE
CUSTOMER SERVICE PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES AND A MUCH NEEDED
TECHNOLOGY REFRESH. WHAT THANK
YOU FOR THAT I DON'T THINK THE
QUESTION WAS WHETHER WE NEED IT
IT'S A QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT
WHAT PROCESS SHOULD WE USED TO
BROUGH PLACES AND AT LEAST
THAT'S MY- THAT'S MY- AND YEAH
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE THE
NEXT POINT OF MY QUESTION- SITE
HERE IS YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD WE
RECOMMEND THAT WE DO AT THIS
POINT. THE RECOMMENDED SOLUTION
IS FOR CS PS TO ACQUIRE AND
COMMERCIAL OFF THE SHELF OFFICE-
SISTER. THIS WOULD INVOLVE THE
BRICK. AND IMPLEMENTATION OF A
FULL HUMAN CAPITAL MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. YOU MAY CAPITAL
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS INCLUDE THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF SUPPORT ALL
THE MAIN BUSINESS CAPABILITIES
THAT ARE IN SCOPE FOR THE CSTS
PROJECT INCLUDING. POSITION
CONTROL PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATION BENEFITS
ADMINISTRATION TIME AND
ATTENDANCE ON OF COURSE PAYROLL.
THE RATIONALE FOR THIS EMERGE
FROM THE CLEAR ADVANTAGES
PROVIDED BY TODAY'S COMMERCIAL
SOLUTIONS. ALONG WITH GIVING
THE STATE THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET ALL OF ITS OBJECTIVES
THE ADVANTAGES INCLUDE
SIMPLIFIED TECHNICAL
ARCHITECTURE. A FASTER TIME TO
BENEFIT. LEVERAGING THE
EXPERTISE OF VENDORS WHO HAVE
BEEN BUILDING NEW SYSTEMS FOR
DECADES. AND THE A MUCH HIGHER
USER ACCEPTANCE RATE. THE COSTS
AROUND IN THIS APPROACH AS YOU
HEARD IS ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT WOULD BE
INCLUSIVE OF THE SUBSCRIPTION
FEES CLOUD HOSTING.
IMPLEMENTATION OF ANCILLARY
SERVICES. WE DID LOOK AT OTHER
SOLUTIONS OF COURSE. ONE OF THE
MAIN- SOLUTIONS WE LOOKED AT
WAS THE ACTUALLY TO- COMPLETE
THECONTINUE TO DEVELOP OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM SO WHAT WE WOULD
DO THERE IS AT ENHANCEMENTS TO
IT TO DEVELOP A MODERN LOOK AND
FEEL. AND- DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE DATA VALIDATION RULES AND
THINGS THAT WE HAD- IN THE PAST
HOWEVER THAT SOLUTION DIDN'T
MEET ALL OF THE OBJECTIVES OF
THIS PROJECT AND IT WOULD CAUSE
US TO NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF TRANSFORMATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO DO. OTHER SOLUTIONS NOT
SPEAK BRIEFLY OF THEM ARE TO
DEVELOP A CUSTOM SOLUTION.
HOWEVER NO NO ONE STEPPED
FORWARD DURING MARKET RESEARCH
DID INDICATE THAT BUILDING A
CUSTOM SOLUTION WOULD BE THE
WAY TO GO- AGAIN THIS MARKET IS
VERY MATURE NOW AND THERE'S
THEIR SOLUTIONS THAT EXIST AND
NO ONE WOULD NEED TO REWRITE
THEM. BEST OF BREED IS ANOTHER
OPTION WHERE YOU ACTUALLY BY.
THE INDIVIDUAL- INDIVIDUAL
COMPONENTS THAT MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE PROJECT AND THEN THE
INTERFACE THEM. BUT AGAIN
DURING MARKET RESEARCH WE ONLY
HAD A HANDFUL OF FIRMS COME
FORWARD AND THEY WOULD ONLY
ADDRESS SPECIFIC LINES OF
BUSINESSES AND THE STATE WOULD
BE POSITION TO HAVE TO BE THE
SYSTEMS INTEGRATOR TO TIE THEM
ALL TOGETHER. AND FINALLY- AS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE S. A. P.
PRODUCT. HOWEVER DURING
CONSULTANT- DURING MARKET
RESEARCH SAME THING NO ONE STEP
FORWARD TO PROPOSE THAT WE DO
THAT. AND THE SOFTWARE ITSELF
IS NOW SEVERAL VERSIONS BEHIND
AND REALLY JUST NOT A VIABLE
OPTION. WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT
I APPRECIATE THE- THE
INFORMATION IT'S VERY VERY
HELPFUL- AND THIS IS AN ITEM
THAT WE WILL- THAT WILL REMAIN
OPEN IN SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTION WILL MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT ITEM. WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT INTERNAL
CONTROL REVIEWS. BERMAN THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ZERO
IS REQUESTING A SHIFT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENT FORTY
TO GENERAL FUND SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT TO SUPPORT FIVE
EXISTING RESOURCES TO PERFORM
ONGOING INVESTIGATIVE REVIEWS
IN THE OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. PURSUANT
TO GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION
TWELVE FOR TWO TWO POINT FIVE
THIS REQUEST IS A NET ZERO
BRUCE REQUEST FOR THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT PRESENTATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS. DOMINIC
AIR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL. VERY MUCH.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ANY COMMENTS. AT HOLLINGSHEAD
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS ITEM
IS ALSO A HOLDOVER OPEN ITEM
AND SEE NO QUESTIONS ALL MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO WHICH IS A CONTINUATION OF
ENHANCED FRAUD INVESTIGATION
AND PREVENTION ACTIVITIES. THE
DEPARTMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JULIE ACROSS AND I AM
THE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OVER
THE ADMINISTRATION LICENSING
AND SERVICES BRANCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE RCTI THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OUTLINES OUR
CONTINUATION OF ENHANCE FRAUD
INVESTIGATION AND PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR YOU TODAY. C. I.
MONITORS AND PROSECUTE SEVERAL
KEY CAM ACTIONS ALSO REFERRED
TO AS A WHISTLEBLOWER CASES
FILED UNDER THE INSURANCE
FRAUDS PREVENTION ACT. PURSUANT
TO CALIFORNIAN CHURCH SECTION
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. TWENTY
SEVEN HER THIS STATUTE ANY
ASSESSMENTS AND FEES AWARDED
ARE PAID TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AND THE SAME STATUTE ALSO
PROVIDES FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROPRIATE THESE FUNDS TO THE
CBI FOR ENHANCED FRAUD
INVESTIGATION EFFORTS. SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN AS A RESULT OF
OUR EFFORTS HE CAN RECOVERIES
ARE SETTLEMENT PAYMENTS HAVE
TOTALED A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE POINT TWO MILLION WITH
OVER SIXTY SIX MILLION GOING TO
THE GENERAL FUND. IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS HAS ALREADY
BEEN RECOVERED AND DEPOSITED IN
THE GENERAL FUND AS A RESULT OF
OUR EFFORTS. SINCE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS APPROVED
MULTIPLE ONE TIME REQUESTS
TOTALING FIFTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION IN AS MANY AS FIFTY
LIMITED TERM POSITION. OR
SENIORITY UTILIZE THESE FUNDS
FOR ENHANCED FRAUD PREVENTION.
INVESTIGATION WALDRON FINE
RESOURCE WILLIS G. THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEREFORE
CDI'S REQUESTING SIX POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONVERT
THIRTY FOUR EXPIRING LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS. TO PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THESE EFFORTS
THESE EFFORTS INCLUDE THE
MONITORING AND- LITIGATION OF
WHISTLEBLOWER CASES.
INVESTIGATION OF SUSPECTED
FRAUD WITH AN EMPHASIS ON CASES
HAVING IN EXCESS OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SUSPECTED
LOSSES. AND ONGOING MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS ARE FRAUD DATA
ANALYTICS SYSTEM WHICH WE
IMPLEMENTED USING PRIOR GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES. MADE POSSIBLE
BY QUI TAM RECOVERIES
ADDITIONALLY BEGINNING IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
EVERY THREE FISCAL YEARS ARE
AFTER REQUESTING SIX HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THE EDISCOVERY
SOFTWARE AS A SERVICE
SUBSCRIPTION AND THIS IS
ANOTHER GREAT ENHANCEMENT
THAT'S BEEN MADE POSSIBLE BY.
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES AND OUR
KEYCHAIN RECOVERIES. THE
FINDINGS HE HAS REQUESTED WOULD
COME FROM CD I WOULD COME FROM
KEY TEN RECOVERIES SEE I
COLLECTS AS A RESULT OF THE
SUPPLEMENTS THAT ARE PAID TO
THE GENERAL FUND. SO IN
CONCLUSION THIS PROPOSAL WILL
PROVIDE C. I. WITH THE SKILLED
PERSONNEL AND VITAL
TECHNOLOGICAL RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN THIS
PROGRAM. SECURING PERMANENT
FUNDING WILL PROVIDE MORE
CONTINUITY THE PROGRAM
RESULTING IN MORE CASES BEING
MONITORED AND MITIGATED. WHICH
WILL RESULT IN A GREATER RETURN
TO THE GENERAL FUND AS WELL AS
BEING ABLE TO INVESTIGATE MORE
FRAUD CASES. THIS IN TURN WILL
DIRECTLY BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS BY PROTECTING THEM
FROM FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES AND
HELPS TO INSULATE CONSUMERS
FROM THE ALTERNATE COSTS OF
INSURANCE FRAUD. WHICH IS
PASSED ON TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS IN THE FORM OF HIGHER
INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND FEES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR PROPOSAL
WE'D. BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. VERY
GOOD UP FINANCING COMMENTS.
EARLY IN FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE ENHANCE
FRAUD INVESTIGATION AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM WITH ONGOING
RESOURCES. THANKS VERY MUCH L.
A. O. ANY COMMENTS. YES THIS IS
BRAND WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WHICH IS NOT THAT WELL WE HAVE
NO CONCERNS WITH THE- THE ON
GOING I'M SORRY WITH THE-
ENHANCED- INSURANCE FRAUD
INVESTIGATION FRAUD PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AND- WE NOTE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORTED
FUNDING FOR THESE SORTS OF
ACTIVITIES IN THE PAST. I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT IS ALWAYS BEEN
ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS BECAUSE
OF THE- THE FUNDS ARE BEHIND
THEM GOING INTO THE GENERAL
FUND RUN A NON RECURRING AND
OCCASIONALLY SPORADIC BASIS AND
COULD BE SPORADIC IN THE
FUTURE- HOWEVER WE DO KNOW THAT
THE DEPARTMENT MAKES REASONABLE
ARGUMENTS OR ONGOING FUNDING
SO- WE JUST WANT TO LIKE THIS
ISSUE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
WHETHER ON THE LEGISLATURE
AGREES THAT. I'M GOING FUNDING
IS APPROPRIATE IN LIGHT OF THE
NON RECURRING NATURE OF THIS
PARTICULAR SOURCE OF GENERAL
FUND RIGHT NOW AND- BUT MEMBERS
DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PROVIDING ON GOING FUNDING THEN
YOU COULD CONSIDER PROVIDING
FUNDING ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS
AS THE CITY'S DONE PRIOR YEARS.
WE JUST NOTED THERE MAY BE
OTHER WAYS- TO ALLOW ONGOING
FUNDING WILL MAKING SURE
THERE'S APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT-
AND THAT THE- THAT THE- THE
SETTLEMENT AND JUDGMENT FUNDS-
CONTINUE TO COVER THE ONGOING
EXPENSES IN LATER YEARS WITH
SOME SORT OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENT OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM MADE HAPPY BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH STUFF IF THAT. IS
SOMETHING YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
PURSUING. VERY GOOD I. THAT-
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION THIS IS A HOLD
OLD HOLD OPEN ITEM SO WILL-
WE'LL HOLD IT OPEN AND- TAKING
UP IT. FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION
AT A LATER TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE US SECRETARY OF STATE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE WHICH
IS CAL ACCESS REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM PROJECT. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR ME AND SEE ME OKAY. MY
NAME IS JULIE WHAT DELL I AM
THE CHIEF OF THE POLITICAL
REFORM DIVISION AND PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM ON THE CARS
PROJECT I AM JOINED TODAY BY
KEVIN STARR. WHO IS THE
SOLUTION IMPLEMENTATION MANAGER
AND CREWS NATURAL WHO IS THE
PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR US LAST
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO CHILDREN YOU
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
I'M I'M ALSO HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT THERE ARE SEVENTEEN
BUSINESS DAYS REMAINING BEFORE
WE GO LIVE WITH THE FIRST
RELEASE IN IMPLEMENTATION BY
THE END OF THIS MONTH THE NEW
KOCSIS WILL BE LIVE FOR
INTERNAL USERS AND SELECT
STAKEHOLDERS. I'M IN FACT ON
MONDAY OF THIS WEEK WE
CONDUCTED A LIVE DEMONSTRATION
FOR MEMBERS OF THE MPC OF THEIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
STAFF. BUT WE SHOWED THEM THE
SYSTEM BASED ON QUERIES THAT
THEY POSED DURING THE SESSION
AND WE RECEIVED AFTER THE DEMO
ALSO THE FEEDBACK. ON THE CARS
PROJECT TEAM HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING UPDATES AND DEMOS FOR
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL
THROUGHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS INCLUDING TREASURES
ASSOCIATION. ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION SOFTWARE VENDORS
ACTIVITY GOOD GOVERNMENT GROUPS
AND WE HAVE SEVERAL MORE
PLANNED BEFORE THE- FINAL
RELEASE IN JUNE. WE'VE ALSO
SHARED A DEMONSTRATION WITH
STAFF FROM THE LEGISLATURE IN
IN DECEMBER. I'M BY THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR BEFORE JUNE
THIRTIETH THE SYSTEM WILL BE
CERTIFIED. SYSTEM OF RECORD AND
USE FOR PUBLIC ACCESS- AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ENCOUNTERS OUTAGES ON A
REGULAR BASIS- IN ARCHITECTURE
WE CURRENTLY HAVE IS NO LONGER
SUPPORTED. OBJECT IS ESSENTIAL
TO PUBLIC ASSET ACCESS TO THE
DISCLOSURE INFORMATION
POLITICS. IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY SOS MADE THE DECISION TO
SWITCH TO A NEW PLATFORM I WE
HAVE A NEW MANAGEMENT TEAM NEW
VENDOR AND YOU PLATFORM- WE ARE
ALIGNED- FOR A SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION AND THIS B. P.
B. C. P. ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF
THE PROJECT. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE IS REQUESTING
THE AMOUNT OF SEVEN POINT FOUR
THREE NINE MILLION AND IT
BREAKS DOWN AS A ONE POINT NINE
MILLION. APPROXIMATELY FOUR
STOCKS ACROSS THREE DIVISIONS
THAT'S TWELVE P. WINDS AS WELL
AS I. T. TECHNOLOGY FOR
SOFTWARE. AND AS YOU KNOW
BASICALLY AND THEN- SERVICES
FOR CONFIGURATION AS WELL AS
CLOUD. SERVICES SUPPORT AND
SLIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR- AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO FIELD ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANXIOUS TO SEE
THE PROJECT AS IT THE GOES LIVE
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT
WHAT SO FAR SEEMS TO BE WORKING
PRETTY WELL- ANY COMMENTS FROM.
BERMAN A FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TOMORROW JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AT THIS
REQUEST TO- FIND THE CADILLACS
AS REPLACEMENT SYSTEM PROJECT
THANK YOU. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST ON OFFICE ANY COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS NICK
SCHROEDER WITH THE L. A. O. WE
BRACE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL OR ANY OF THE OTHER
SECRETARY STATE PROPOSALS. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM AND SO WE
WILL DO SO AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE. CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
CONNECT PROJECT. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN GUERRIERO- I AM BETSY
BOGARD I AM THE CHIEF OF THE
BUSINESS PROGRAMS DIVISION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY STATE
AND CO SPONSOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS CONNECT
PROJECT. WE ARE HERE TO REQUEST
A CONTINUATION OF FUNDING IN
THE AMOUNT OF ELEVEN POINT SIX
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN-
SPENDING AUTHORITY FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- THESE IT
WILL BE PAID FROM THE FEES THAT
BUSINESSES ARE PAYING FOR OUR
SERVICES. IT BREAKS DOWN TO
EIGHT POINT ONE SEVEN FOUR
MILLION FROM THE BUSINESS FEES
FINE AND THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION FROM THE BUSINESS
PROGRAMS MODERNIZATION FUND
WHICH WAS CREATED TO. ALL
MODERNIZE OUR- BOTTOM
AUTOMATION WITHIN THE BUSINESS
PROGRAMS DIVISION. AND WE'RE IN
OUR FINAL PHASE AND I AM HAPPY
TO ANNOUNCE WITH THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS CONNECT
PROJECT IT'S ALL GOING VERY
WELL- WITH THE ADDED- CHALLENGE
OF KOBE. AND WE NEED TO GAIN
ALL EFFICIENCIES AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN BROUGH AUTOMATION- FOR THE
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS AND ALSO
TO KEEP OUR ECONOMY MOVING
FORWARD WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE-
MA'AM THE ONLY QUESTION I HAVE
IS- IS IF WE KNOW AT THIS TIME
WHAT THE- THE- OMB WITH. WILL
BE. OUR OWN M. WILL BE TOO MANY
LETTERS. THE OPERATING
OPERATION AND MANAGEMENT ACOSTA
IF WE KNOW WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
BE IN THE FUTURE- WE DON'T HAVE
THAT EXACTLY AT THIS POINT- WE
ARE SCHEDULED TO GO LIVE- WITH
THE FINAL PHASE IN. DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND THEN
WILL HAVE A YEAR OF MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS- SO WE'LL LIKELY
HAVE ANOTHER ROUND OF FUNDING.
AND THEN DO A FINAL PEER AN
EVALUATION OF- HOW MANY STAFF
DO WE REALLY NEED TO. MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE MEETING THE
BUSINESSES NEEDS- WE CAN ONLY
GET YOU ESTIMATES- BUT AT THIS
POINT. THEY ARE PURELY
ESTIMATES. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
FOR THAT INFORMATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS. TOMORROW JOHNSON
PERMANENTLY NANCY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL. LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS
OFFICE COMMENTS. BUT NICK
SCHROEDER NO NOTHING TO ADD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO JUST TO
CONFUSE READY I SKIPPED OVER
ONE JUST TO SEE IF WE WERE ALL
ON OUR TOES SO I APOLOGIZE AND
I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE LIMITED
TERM ACCOUNTING RESOURCES.
HUNDREDS TO BE CURRENT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE THAT THAT
WAS A HOLD OPEN ITEM AND SO
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN. MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS YES
STATEN I'M WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE ON THE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES DIVISION
CHIEF I'M OVERSEEING THE-
FISCAL AFFAIRS BUREAU THE
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT GIRL OUR
HUMAN RESOURCES AND ARE SAFE AT
HOME PROGRAM. NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR BRINGS FORTH THE REQUEST
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
ACCOUNTING AND PROCUREMENT
SECTIONS THAT HAVE INSUFFICIENT
STAFF TO REDUCE ONGOING
BACKGROUND SENATE PASSED
BECAUSE STAFF OVERTIME.
CHALLENGES WITH EMPLOYEE
RETENTION AND DELAYS IN
PAYMENTS AT THE ONSET OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S TRANSITION
ON TO THE FISCAL SYSTEM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WAS ALREADY
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSTAFFED IN
THESE AREAS AND DID NOT HAVE
THE CORRECT ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF OUR DISCOUNT
TRANSITION. RIGHT SIZING IN
CREATING THE APPROPRIATE
STRUCTURE ALLOWS THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE TO HAVE
DEDICATED RESOURCES TO OPERATE
EFFICIENTLY MOVING FORWARD. TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT STAFFING TO
AVOID ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE IS
REQUESTING CONTINUED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THESE TWELVE REQUESTED
RESOURCES. SECRETARY OF STATE
IS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COMMENTS. TOMORROW
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FOR AND
CONTINUED LIMITED TERM
ACCOUNTING RESOURCES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS OFFICE.
NICK SCHROEDER AGAIN- WE RAISE
NO CONCERNS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS TOO IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEMS SO WE WILL DO SO I WILL
MOVE ON TO THE LAST ITEM FOR
THE SECRETARY OF STATE WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX THE
BUSINESS PROGRAMS DIVISION
PROCESSING TIMES. THANK YOU
THAT IS MINE ALSO- BETSY BOGART
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE- WE'RE HERE
AFTER REQUESTING CONTINUATION
OF THE SPENDING AUTHORITY FOR
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NEEDED
TO AGAIN REACH AND MAINTAIN OUR
AVERAGE OF FIVE BUSINESS DAYS
OR BETTER TURN AROUND TIME- FOR
BUSINESS FILINGS AND STATEMENTS
AND INFORMATION. IN THE
BUSINESS PROGRAMS DIVISION-
THIS IS BEN- UTILIZED BY PAST
SECRETARY STATES AND- WITH
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL- IT IS
NEEDED UNTIL CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS CONNECT IS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. AND THANK YOU TO
THE RECENT ONGOING AUTOMATION
AND ONLINE IMPROVEMENTS ESOS
HAS REDUCED THE REQUEST- FOR
ONGOING SUPPORT- FROM FIFTY SIX
POSITIONS DOWN TO FORTY SEVEN
POSITIONS WITH WHICH IS A 16%
REDUCTION- SO AS WE ARE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS CONNECT WE ARE ABLE TO
REDUCE THESE- LIMITED TERM
FUNDED POSITIONS- AND I SHOULD
BE CLEAR THAT THIS IS THE
FUNDING THESE ARE NOT-
POSITIONS THEMSELVES WITH THE
NEW- WAY WE ARE DOING LIMITED
TERM- FUNDED POSITIONS- THIS IS
TO FIGHT WERE ASKING FOR FIVE
POINT ONE ZERO EIGHT MILLION-
WITH THE FORTY WHICH WILL
SUPPORT THE FORTY SEVEN
POSITIONS TEMPORARY HELP AS
WELL AS OVERTIME DURING- THIS
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY.
TWO AND WE HAVE REDUCED IT TO
JUST THE ONE YEAR REQUEST- TO
SEE WHERE WE ARE AT THE END OF.
IMPLEMENTATION OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS CONNECT- THE
AUGMENTATION IS COMING FROM THE
BUSINESS FEES FUND WHICH IS
THAT. THESE BUSINESSES ARE
PAYING FOR OUR SERVICES- AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE-
BUSINESS PRESERVATION
PROCESSING TIMES REQUEST. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS. TOMORROW
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WE SUPPORT THE REQUEST
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. LMAO ANY
COMMENTS. BUT NICK SCHROEDER L.
A- NOTHING TO ADD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THIS AGAIN IS A HOLD
OPEN ITEM SO WILL DO SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE SECRETARY
OF STATE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN ACCOUNTING
WORKLOAD RESOURCES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTER THE CENTER NOW OPEN
ABOUT IS NOT THERE BUT I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
APPEAR BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MARCUS MACARTHUR AND
I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF REAL ESTATE. I WILL PROVIDE
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S MOST RECENT BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALREQUEST FOR
FISCAL YEARS. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING IN
REGARD TO THE ACCOUNTING
WORKLOAD RESOURCES. ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN. FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING
FROM THE REAL ESTATE FUND. THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE FOR ONE
PERMANENT SENIOR ACCOUNTING UP
THE POSITION AND ONE TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM ACCOUNTING OFFICER
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
ACCOUNTING ACTIVITIES AND ARE
FISCAL DEPARTMENT. I'M JOINED
BY JEFF ABILITIES HE ASSISTANT
COMMISSIONER FOR LICENSING SHOW
THE WORLD'S AND ASSISTANT
COMMISSIONER FOR ADMINISTRATION
AND DIRECTLY THE DEPARTMENT.
FINANCE CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
THE TO INCLUDE MY REMARKS AND
WE'RE HAPPY ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS YOU'RE
A REPORT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IT'S NOT A PROBLEM
FINANCING ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SORT OF BORED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE DID NOT
RAISE OUR CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT- THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM
SO WE WILL DO THAT AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH IS THE LICENSING
INFORMATION SECTION CALL
WORKLOAD. MARKET AGAIN- THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
HUNDRED AND THOUSAND DOLLAR
INTO YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
TWO AND THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THE DOLLARS IN TWENTY
THREE. OR TWENTY TWO TWO TO
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWO THREE
TWENTY FOUR THAT'S A MOUTHFUL I
APOLOGIZE- IN THE THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING FOR THE
REAL ESTATE FUND AND THAT WOULD
BE FOR FIVE PROGRAM TECHNICIAN
TO USE TO SUPPORT THE LICENSING
PROGRAM INFORMATION SYSTEM.
STAFF THE STAFF WILL PROVIDE
THE ADDITIONAL STAFFING
NECESSARY TO HELP MANAGE HIGH
CALL VOLUMES AND EXCESSIVE CALI
TIMES INDIA READ LICENSING
PROGRAM. THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS ON TOPIC IN AGAIN WE
WILL BE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IT'S NOT A PERMANENT
FINANCES NOTATIONAL COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD THE L. A.
ALSO OFFICE. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DID NOT RAISE CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD AND
THAT CONCLUDES THIS ITEM IT
WHICH IS A HOLDOVER OPEN SO WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL. AND THAT'S ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE CALIFORNIA
CREATIVE CORE PILOT PROGRAM.
HELLO MY NAME IS AND ON
CRAWFORD AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
I'M HERE WITH MY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR I AND I CAN'T WORRY
AND MY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR-
CHRISTIAN MARGOLIS CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL REQUEST FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CREATIVE CORE PILOT PROGRAM
WITH PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO
SUPPORT A LIMITED TERM STAFFING
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS.
INCLUDE DEVELOPING PROJECT
TIMELINES DEVELOPING PROCEDURES
SETTING UP TRACKING TOOLS ARE
DURING THE HEARING APPLICATIONS
SUBMITTING THE APPLICATIONS TO
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL FOR
APPROVAL AND PROCESSING THEM
EVALUATION AND ASSESSMENT.
CALIFORNIA CREATIVE CORE
PROJECT IS INTENDED TO FUEL
POSITIVITY REGAIN PUBLIC TRUST
AND INSPIRE SAFE AND HEALTHY
BEHAVIOR PARTICULARLY IN OUR
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. THIS
WILL INCLUDE A MEDIA OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGN TO
INCREASE INCREASE THE TRUST
FACTOR ACROSS OUR DIVERSE
POPULATIONS. TO INCREASE
VACCINE ADOPTION. IT WILL BE BY
MAY DOLLARS INVESTMENT FROM THE
STATE MATCHED BY A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR. THE- AMOUNT
FROM PHILANTHROPIC AND PRIVATE
SECTORS WITH BROAD AND DIVERSE
ARTS AND CULTURAL RESOURCES
CALIFORNIANS WELL CREEK
EQUIPPED TO LEAD THE COUNTRY.
IN LAUNCHING A CREATIVE CORE IN
ORDER TO MOBILIZE ARTIST
TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND ARTS
SECTOR. PROCS FOR EFFECTIVE
HYPER LOCAL MICRO TARGETED
PUBLIC COMMUNICATION AND TO
HELP PEOPLE CONNECT COKE AND BE
WELL OW IN THE LONG TERM IT
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED EVEN WITH
THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF CODE
NINETEEN THAT CALIFORNIA'S ARTS
ECOSYSTEM IS AMONG THE MOST
POWERFUL AND CULTURALLY RICH IN
THE WORLD AND SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED. INVESTED IN AND
LEVERAGE. WE WILL PARTNER WITH
STATEWIDE NETWORKS ARE FORMAL
AND INFORMAL CULTURAL DISTRICTS
INTERMEDIARY ORGANIZATIONS AND
STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERS TO
SUPPORT ARTISTS AND
ORGANIZATIONS. WHO WILL BE
DEPLOYING CULTURALLY ROOTED
CREATIVE STRATEGIES TO ADVANCE
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNICATION. TO
REBUILD PUBLIC TRUST AND
CULTIVATE SOCIAL COHESION WILL
WORK WITH ARTISTS PERFORMERS
TRUSTED CULTURE BEARERS WITH A
FOCUS ON BY PARK IN LGBTQ CLASS
ARTISTS WHO WORK IN ART FORMS
SPIRITUAL PRACTICES CULTURAL
TRADITIONS AND SOCIAL MOVEMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TENDED BY AND
ROOTED IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. WE WILL COMMISSION
ARTISTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO CREATE VISUAL
NARRATIVE AND PER FORMATIVE
WORK THAT CAPTURES THIS MOMENT
IN OUR COLLECTIVE HISTORY.
ALLOWS FOR GRIEVING AND FUELS
HEALING INSPIRATION AND JOY.
WELL ECCENTRIC THIS WORK WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE MEDIA OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGN
UTILIZING OUR DIVERSE STATEWIDE
NETWORKS IN ORDER TO FEEL
POSITIVITY AND INCREASE TRUST.
WE ARE HERE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION BOB DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TOMORROW JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE
SUPPORT AT THE PROPOSAL MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY
IF I MADE THAT THE FIVE MILLION
ALLOCATION IS PART OF THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE AND THE EXAMINER
TEN MILLION IS A TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I APPRECIATE THAT. FOR
THE TEN MILLION IS THE. TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. CORRECT GOT IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHELLO'S
OFFICE. SORT OF BORED
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
BOMB WE FIND THAT THE CONCEPT
OF USING ART TO PROMOTE PUBLIC
HEALTH MESSAGING HAS MERIT-
HOWEVER WE FIND THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL KEY IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL-
REMAIN UNANSWERED. ONE OF THE
FIRST QUESTION WE HAVE IS WHO
WOULD ADMINISTER THE GRANT AT
THIS TIME ARTS COUNCIL'S TRYING
TO DECIDE WHETHER IT WOULD
DIRECTLY ALLOCATE FUNDS TO-
ARTISTS IN THE FIELD OR IT
WOULD RELY ON LOCAL PARTNERS TO
IDENTIFY AN ARTIST THAT WOULD
RECEIVE THE GRANTS. OR IF THE
GRANT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH A COMBINATION OF THESE
TWO SIR- APPROACHES ON THERE'S
VARIOUS PROS AND CONS TO EITHER
OF THESE APPROACHES FOR EXAMPLE
AT THE ARTS COUNCIL
ADMINISTERED IT ADDING MORE
STATEWIDE LEVEL YOU COULD
EXPECT GREATER UNIFORMITY. OR
IS IT WAS ALLOCATED MORE BY
LOCAL PARTNERS- D. INDIVIDUALS
ACTUALLY AWARDING THE GRANT
MIGHT HAVE MORE INSIGHT INTO
pTARGETED. IN EITHER CASE THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO WANT TO
GET CLARITY FROM ARTS COUNCIL
ON HOW IT'S GOING TO ADMINISTER
THE GRANT. IN ADDITION- WHILE
LEAD COUNSEL HAS INDICATED- AS
YOU HEARD THAT FUNDS ARE GOING
TO BE TARGETED AT COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
INCLUDING HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES-
THERE'S A LOT ABOUT THE
ALLOCATION PROCESS THAT WE
DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT. SUCH
AS WHAT OTHER CRITERIA WOULD BE
CONSIDERED AND HOW THESE
CRITERIA WOULD BE WEIGHED
AGAINST EACH OTHER THIS IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP
THE LEGISLATURE IDENTIFY
WHETHER OR NOT THE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO BE TARGETED IN A WAY
THAT WOULD BE MOST EFFECTIVE.
TO ADDRESS CODE NINETEEN.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS HOW PEOPLE
WOULD BE FIVE GRANT- YOU HEARD.
OF THAT COUNCILS HOPING TO WORK
WITH- AROUND FIVE HUNDRED
ARTISTS REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. HOWEVER AT THIS
POINT IT'S DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
HOW MANY PEOPLE MIGHT ENCOUNTER
THE ARTWORK THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTED. AND THAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO COMPARE THIS STRATEGY
AGAINST OTHER STRATEGIES THAT
MIGHT CONSIDER TO GET OUT
PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGES LIKE
ADVERTISING. IT'S ALSO A BIT
UNCLEAR EXACTLY HOW THE
MATCHING ELEMENTS OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM WOULD WORK AND IT WE
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO GET CLARITY
ON THISASPECT OF THE PROGRAM
TO ENSURE THAT IT DOESN'T.
CERTAINLY LIMIT WHICH ARTISTS
ARE ABLE TO. PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. ALL AT THIS TIME WE
FIND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD WITHHOLD ACTION ON THE
PROPOSAL UNTIL THESE KEY
IMPLEMENTATION QUESTIONS ARE
ANSWERED HOWEVER IF THESE
QUESTIONS ARE ANSWERED TO THE
SATISFACTION OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE LEGISLATURE FINDS THAT
ON THIS COULD BE A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF GETTING OUT
HEALTH MESSAGING WE RECOMMEND
APPROVAL OBVIOUSLY. ARE THESE
QUESTIONS REMAIN UNANSWERED OR
THE ANSWERS ARE NOT TO THE
SATISFACTION OF THE LEGISLATURE
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE I USE THIS FUNDING
IN OTHER WAYS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR OUR COMMENT-
SO I JUST WANNA BY SECOND AT
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE L. A. O. FOR THE
ARTS COUNCIL- I THINK- I AM I A
SUPPORT THE ARTS ND I THINK
THEY'RE IMPORTANT IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR SO MANY REASONS
AND- RIGHT NOW. THERE'S A REAL
LACK OF HOPE IN THE COMMUNITY-
THE BACKS AND BAXEEN QUITE
FRANKLY OUR- OUR THE ONE BRIGHT
LIGHT ADDED ADDED THESE PAST.
TEN OR ELEVEN MONTHS- BUT I AM
CONCERNED AND REPRESENTING A
RURAL RURAL AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICT. WITH LOTS OF
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES UP THE
MY EXPERIENCE IS THAT THE FUNDS
DON'T END UP GETTING DOWN TO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT FOR THE MOST PART-
ART. TENDS TO BE- SEEN AS A AT
EIGHT AM. A FEATURE OF MORE
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND YOU SEE
A LOT MORE INVESTMENT IN THOSE
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN
IN- DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M I'M GONNA NEED A LOT
MORE INFORMATION AND I'D LIKE
IF YOU COULD- TO- GET TO THE%
THIS COMMITTEE A LIST OF THE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT YOU
HAVE HELP TO FIND IN PAST YEARS
SO THAT WE CAN GET AN IDEA OF
THE KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT.
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
ARTS COUNCIL AND WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED- AND HOW MUCH HAS BEEN
INVESTED IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT MIGHT TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHETHER. THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE IN THIS GRANT
APPLICATION OUR OUR RESOURCES
THAT SHOULD GO TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL AS OPPOSED. TO GOING
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE TO
COMMUNITIES ON THROUGH THEIR
SCHOOLS OR SOME OTHER MECHANISM
THAT- THAT MAKES SENSE IN TERMS
OF THIS STATE STATE GOVERNMENT
INVESTMENT I THINK WE SHOULD
INVEST THIS MONEY I GUESS
THAT'S MY FIRST PART BUT BUT
THIS IS A HOLLOW OPEN ITEM AND
I'D FOUND BY AYE I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE L. A- IF YOU
COULD IN TERMS OF WHO WOULD
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM. LOCAL
PARTNERS OR YOURSELF- HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT MATCHED THE
MATCHING GRANTS DON'T RESTRICT.
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE A HARD
TIME RAISING THE MONEY TO DO A
MATCH. AND AND HOW YOU AND
INVASION. REALLY GETTING INTO
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IT MAY
NOT HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE BY WAY OF A ARTS COUNCIL
OR A- OR- A REAL ACTIVE-
ORGANIZATION HOW DO YOU FIND
WHEN THAT THAT DOESN'T OCCUR IN
A COMMUNITY. IT WAS THAT IT
WASN'T A QUESTION YES. YES IT
WAS A FAIRLY LONG QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE. RIGHT JUST TODAY TO
MAKE SURE ANSWER NOW WITH THE
CLARITY THAT YOU WANT WE HAVE
PARTNERS IN OUR FIFTY EIGHT OF
THAT OUT. IN FIFTY FOUR OUT OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. DOWN
THAT OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DESIGNATED. ARTS
COUNCILS AND THEN THE THEN WE
REACH OUT TO THE OTHER COUNTIES
THROUGH OUR- COOPERATIVE
AGREEMENTS WITH ADJACENT
COUNTIES GEOGRAPHY MATTERS TO
US RURAL- GEOGRAPHY MATTERS TO
US TREMENDOUSLY IT'S ONE OF THE
COUNCIL'S PRIORITIES. AND THAT
IS A PRIORITY OF THIS PROJECT
AS WELL IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WERE- WE'RE SO EXCITED
ABOUT THIS IS BECAUSE IT GIVES
US AN OPPORTUNITY WHEN I SAY
MICRO TARGETED. TO GO TO THOSE
RURAL COMMUNITIES FOR EXAMPLE
THERE ARE ARE THAT HAVE VERY
RICH CULTURAL ARTS. WITH THE IN
THEM NOT THE FINE ARTS IN THE
FANCY GALLERIES BUT THE YOU
KNOW THE CULTURAL ARTS AND BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN THAT VOICE TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES. WHETHER YOU
KNOW BE- HISPANIC OR LATINO OR-
NATIVE AMERICAN YOU KNOW TO BE
BIRDS ON THE GROUND AT THIS.
YEAH MESSAGING SOME. IT IS THE
INTENT TO REACH THE WHOLE STATE
IN EVERY COUNTY AND NOT BE TOP
DOWN MESSAGING BECAUSE WE FEEL
VERY DEEPLY THAT IT WOULD BE
MORE EFFECTIVE. VERY GOOD WELL
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM SO I
EXPECT WE'LL WE'LL SEE YOU BACK
AGAIN- IN TERMS OF THAT- WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THE PAST IF
YOU COULD GET US ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT THAT WOULD
BE GRETLY APPRECIATED.
ABSOLUTELY GREAT THANK YOU.
AFTER KENNEDY THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO. ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY IT'S ON THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. CALVET
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
PROJECT PHASES TWO AND THREE.
AFTERNOON SHARE AND SENATOR
NELSON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE MY NAME
IS ANTHONY WARS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS I'M THE
PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR THE CALVET
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
PROJECT. THIS PROJECT WILL
IMPLEMENT A NEW LONG TERM CARE
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM
AND ALL EIGHT VETERANS HOMES OF
CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
HEADQUARTERS OFFICE. THIS
REQUEST IS FOR A ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE
SECOND YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION.
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDES NINE POINT SIX MILLION
FOR PRIMARY VENDOR CONTRACT.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND FOR
OUR INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION
AND VALIDATION SERVICES AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FOUR DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
OVERSIGHT COSTS. IN REGARDS TO
THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
PROJECT DIFFICULT IMPACTS WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE SCHEDULE DELAYS.
NO HOMES HAVE IMPLEMENTED THUS
FAR. WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PLANNING PHASE. TO DATE NO
PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE TO THE
VENDOR BECAUSE THE INITIAL SET
OF DELIVERABLES ARE ZERO COST
DELIVERABLES. WITH OUR
EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEE
SUPPORT WE HAVE BEGUN AN EFFORT
TO RE BASELINE OR PROJECT
SCHEDULE. WE DO NOT EXPECT THAT
THIS WILL RESULT IN A SPECIAL
PROJECT REPORT. EXCUSE ME WE DO
EXPECT THAT THIS EFFORT WILL
RESULT IN A SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT KNOW THE
FULL IMPACTS OF THIS CHANGE.
I'M SURE WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT PRESENTATION
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE LAST.
THE LAWS ONE PARTNER FINANCE. I
WAS BORN BERMAN PLANTS GOOD
AFTERNOON. FINEST HAS NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROJECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO
COMMENT. THANK YOU BROCHURE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE AS NOTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT- IN DECEMBER THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY DID
CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT PROJECT
REVIEW OF THE ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORDS IN WHICH STATE FLAG-
TWO ISSUES ONE BEING THE DELAYS
OF A NUMBER OF PROJECT PLAN
DELIVERABLES BUT ALSO CONCERNS
ABOUT THE POSSIBLE IMPACTS. OF
THOSE DELAYS ON THE TIMING OF
QUALITY REVIEW FEEDBACK PROCESS
BUT AS THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONED
THERE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING
TOWARDS MITIGATING THESE DELAYS
AND ALSO LOOKING AT WAYS TO
EXTEND THE PROJECT TIMELINE TO
ENSURE THAT THE INITIAL QUALITY
REVIEW AND FEEDBACK TIME FRAME
IS MAINTAINED SO JUST WHAT THAT
SAID- THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO REQUEST THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION KEEPING UP TO
DATE ON THESE CONVERSATIONS ANY
RELATED REBASE LINING UP THE
PROJECT SCHEDULE AND WHEN THAT
SPECIAL REPORT BECOMES
AVAILABLE. AND TO SHARE THAT SO
THAT INFORMATION CAN. BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT-
THOSE COMMENTS AND- THIS IS
ALSO A HOLD OPEN ITEM AND I
WANNA- SECOND WITH THE L. A. O.
HAS TO SAY ABOUT- KEEPING THE
LEGISLATURE. ABREAST OF THE-
THE DELAYS AND THE DELIVERABLES
AS WELL AS THE IMPACT ON LONG
TERM I MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
THAT USUALLY WE HAVE
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THAT DID IT AND IT'S TOTALLY
NATURAL TO EXPECT THAT DURING
THE BIGGEST. BOB PANDEMIC THAT
OUR COUNTRY HAS SEEN IN. IN
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS THAT THAT
THERE WOULD BE DELAYS TO
PROJECTS BUT GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
CONTRACT THERE ARE CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT THE TIMELINE
CAN BE EXTENDED THAT THERE ARE
NO PENALTIES INVOLVED IN THAT
IN THAT- THE PROJECT CAN MOVE
FORWARD IN IN AN X.
EXPEDITION'S MANNER SO- WANNA
URGE THAT- THE- DEPARTMENT TO
KEEP US TO KEEP US ABREAST OF
ALL OF THAT IF YOU COULD. WE
WILL DO THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATED THAT ITEM WILL
REMAIN WELL AT. LEAST WE'RE
GONNA HOLD OPEN. AND WILL TAKE
UP ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE
WHICH IS THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY.
EAGLE COLUMN BAHRIA. EXPANSION.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DAVID GERARD AND THE ASSISTANT
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
MY RESPONSIBILITIES ARE THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROGRAM FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- WHAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS A PROPOSAL FOR
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
VETERANS CEMETERY AND I GO
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
COLUMBARIUM EXPANSION REQUEST
IT IS THE REQUEST FUNDING FOR
JUST THE PRELIMINARY PLANS AND
WORKING DRAWINGS PHASES THE
DESIGN WORK THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO CONSTRUCTION
OF TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
COLUMBARIUM NICHES. IN DECEMBER
OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WE HAD A
TOTAL OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN REMAINING
COLUMBARIUM NICHES IT IS A
LITTLE IT IS OUR ANTICIPATION
THAT THOSE COLUMBARIUM NICHES
WILL BE EXHAUSTED PROBABLY BY
THIS SUMMER AT THE RATE WE'RE
GOING THE DESIGN WILL GIVE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO ADVANCE
PLANNING CAN BE POSITIONED FOR
REQUESTING CONSTRUCTION FROM
THE US TV A CONSTRUCTION CREW
I'M SORRY THE U. S. TVA
CEMETERY GRANT PROGRAMS- THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. I AM NOT
PREPARED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THERE ARE NO WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- CONCERNS.
THANK YOU COMMENT COMMENTS FROM
THE L. A. L. CHECK DIVERSITY OF
LA- NO CONCERNS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BOB THIS IS A OF HOLD OPEN
WHICH WE WILL DO. SO NOW WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF OUR HEARING
AT THE END I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE- I THE TESTIMONY THAT
WE'VE HAD HERE TODAY SO FAR.
BUT NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF OUR
HEARING REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
THAT WE'VE HAD ON THE CALENDAR
TODAY. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARD REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARING.
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. TODAY
I'M GOING TO ASK THAT EACH
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING
COMMENT KEEP THE REMARKS WITHIN
ONE MINUTE. NOW LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE INTHE
ROOM AND I'M LOOKING AROUND AND
I DON'T SEE ANY. SO TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ALSO
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISH WISHING TO
PROVIDE. I'VE GONE BACK ON MY
SORRY ABOUT THAT. SO WE'VE
ALREADY ANNOUNCED THE NUMBER SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
WAIT TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO PART PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
BILLS SAYING NO ONE IN THE ROOM
AT TWENTY FORTY. THANK YOU SO
WILL MOVE NOW ONTO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
SURE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
THE PHONE. AND YOU NEED TO HAVE
THANK YOU BE JUST A MOMENT.
VERY GOOD GEN. AND AS A
REMINDER ANY COMMENTS VIA PHONE
AT TWO ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO JUST A
MOMENT BEFORE YOUR FIRST
COMMENT. WE WILL ALL COMBINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR CAPPIELLO
NICE TO SEE YOU DIGITALLY. I AM
JOHN SCRIPT- CENTER NIELSEN I'M
JOHN SCRIPT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
RESPECT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REALIST STATES REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
WORKLOAD THE CALL CENTER. AS
PART OF THEIR REQUEST IS
SERVICE ORIENTED FOR OUR
MEMBERS AND OTHERS AND WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THE COMMISSIONER'S
REQUEST FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. FOR THAT WE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENT. AND AGAIN IF THERE ARE
ANY COMMENTS LONDON'S THERE'LL
BE A THE PHONE. THEIR NUMBER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO WE ARE FIVE
FINISHED WITH ALL OUR CALLERS A
SO THANK YOU TO THE MODERATOR
FOR HELPING US TODAY- WANT TO
ASK US SENATOR NELSON IF HE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS HE
WANTS TO MAKE TODAY BEFORE WE
BEGIN OUR VOTING. MADAM CHAIR
JUST TO APOLOGIZE FOR MY
DELAYED BUT WE HAD A DEPUTY
SHERIFF MURDERED NIGHT OF
ATTENDED THE FUNERAL SO. BUT
I'M READY TO GO NOW TO GET TO
THE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR AND OUR CONDOLENCES- TO
THE FAMILY- IT'S ALWAYS HARD TO
LA. TO LOSE A FAMILY MEMBER
AND- IT'S GREAT AND IT'S A HARD
THING TO GO TO A FUNERAL SO I
DO APPRECIATE THAT- THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AND WHO GAVE
TESTIMONY TODAY. IT SHARE
PARTICIPATION AND- YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU STAYING ON ON
THE LINE AND TESTIFYING WE WILL
NOW VOTE ON ISSUES FIVE SIX.
NINE AND ELEVEN THROUGH.
NINETEEN I WILL MOVE THAT WE
APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR THESE ISSUES.
IS THERE A SECOND SECOND. THERE
IS A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HER HAIR
BY NIELSEN. NIELSEN NINE. THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.